-Finally, guys, it's Tuesday,
it's time for "WeTweet."
Here we go!
-♪ WeTweet ♪
♪ WeTweet ♪
-Welcome to "WeTweet."
This is where we, as a group,
decide something that we should
post on Twitter.
I'm gonna show you five
different tweets, and we're all
gonna vote on whether you like
each one or not.
You all have voting clickers at
your seats.
See them?
Yeah, there you go there.
You can vote for all of them,
you can vote for none of them,
whatever you want.
And we're gonna see the results
live right now.
Higgins, you got one?
-Got it.
-Roots, you have your clickers
too? Tariq?
-Got 'em.
-Whatever tweet gets the most
likes, we will tweet it out
live on the show
so that you can all like it
and "wetweet" it.
[ Audience ahs ]
It's a shared experience.
Alright, you guys
ready for this?
The first tweet is...
Yeah, there you go.
Alright. Quest, you're going to
press thumbs up just to be nice?
-I like my job, man.
-Yep, alright.
Higgins, what are you going to
give it?
-You don't wanna know.
[ Laughter ]
-You don't think that's the one?
-I don't, I don't.
-Alright, it's the first one
out.
-This is a tester.
-They don't necessarily get
better.
I'm just gonna say this.
[ Laughter ]
Just so we know
right off the bat.
Okay, one in the middle might be
better than this.
Who knows?
-We don't know.
-Alright, but we kind of know
the results here.
Everyone is just stunned.
They already pressed down.
They're, like, looking at me.
But let's see the results
so we know this is
real and not -- Wow.
-Wow. Wow!
-Wow!
That might be the worst one
we've ever done.
-41, that's a record.
-Alright.
[ Laughter ]
-Whoo!
-You guys don't have to be
that honest, okay?
It's up to you.
Humans did write those jokes.
I mean, they have feelings
as well.
-Don't be cruel.
-Alright.
This next one is, "I'm not
scared of heights
but I am scared of when
my waiter takes my order
without writing anything down."
[ Laughter ]
"No, no, no, I'm good,
I'm good.
Yeah, yeah.
No, yeah, you want it medium?
Okay, yeah. No problem.
No, I'll remember.
Yeah, okay, yeah.
And you want that? Okay.
Okay, no, no problem,
no, I'll remember.
Yeah, you want a side of that?
Okay. You can't have that?
Okay. Is there any allergies?
Alright, I got it. I got it.
No, I got it."
Let's see the results.
Oh!
-Wow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Now you're being nice.
I love you guys.
-Wow, that was backlash.
-You guys are being so nice.
Thank you.
-That was like
a whiplash effect.
-That was too nice 'cause that
wasn't even that funny.
They're just being nice.
-I feel guilty, yeah.
-But I love that you did that.
There's a lot of love
in this room.
-They went, "This makes sense."
-This is good. I like this.
I mean, that's the extremes
right there, yeah.
Alright.
This next one here says...
[ Laughter ]
-Ooh. Spicy.
-"A sensual back scratch."
-Mm.
-[ Laughs ]
Yeah, come on. Why not?
I don't know.
-Come on. Mother Earth?
-Who knows. Mother Earth?
I love Mother Earth.
-Yeah.
-"Sensual back scratch."
-Yeah, I love it.
-That makes me laugh.
"Sensual" makes me --
Alright, let's see the results
on this one.
Yeah, yeah,
that's what I thought.
Alright, good, not bad.
[ Applause ]
Not bad. On other nights that
would have won.
-Yeah.
-But not tonight, no.
Alright, how about
this one here?
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
-I don't know.
-Is this called "WeedTweet"
or "WeTweet"?
-No, not "weed" --
not "WeedTweet."
-Not "WeedTweet"? Okay.
-No, "we."
-"WeTweet." Okay, got it.
I'm voting.
-"Napkins should be called
lapkins."
-Right.
Because they go on your lap.
-That's correct.
-Right.
Not chinkins, yeah.
-Alright.
I think I know where
this one's leaning.
Alright, let's see the results
on this one.
Yeah, I agree, I agree.
[ Sad tuba ]
I agree. Alright, here we go.
One last one to --
if we don't do this one,
then which one
are we going with?
We're going with the waiter?
-Yes.
-Yeah, we're going with
the waiter one.
If not, then there's this one or
Alright, here we go.
The last one is...
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, I mean,
that's pretty relatable.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, I'm like,
"I know it's on that side.
I've been doing it for years."
You go, "No, it's not, it's on
the other side."
Alright. Here we go.
Let's see the results
on this one.
No, there we go!
It's the waiter.
We're going with
WeTweet number two.
[ Bell dinging ]
I will post this during
the commercial break.
If you see it on your feed,
give it a like,
give it a "wetweet," and enjoy.
Thank you for the honesty
and the love.